so there is on the left are those
essentially are people who think that
society is too unequal and that the
government should be doing something
about it
those on the right are those who so look
at the end of the day if we're all going
to be better off we need to create the
incentives for people to take risks and
that therefore means that they have the
end of day some people who successfully
take risks have to be well paid so you
know that's a continuing arm in our
society about what's the best way to
advance
that's essentially didn't read enough to
write and that is the division that for
the most part at election time you know
if you are right-wing you more like to
vote conservative you're laughing you're
more like to vote Labour
however brexit is not about left versus
right if you are about good versus evil
[Laughter]
this is what happens every time
both Francis and I voted remain but
we're both quite concerned about you
know democracy being thwarted and all
the rest of it but just to annoy a lot
of my audience every time we mention the
fact that I mentioned the fact that we
vote to remain Francis says because
we're good people and then we get a
massive wall of YouTube comments having
a go at us for saying that and it's not
become a joke we're not trying to pin
you down but you're inflicted on
yourself we now have people saying when
are you going to start selling t-shirts
which say which say I voted remain
because I'm a good person anyway I'm
really glad you started talking about
because I was gonna ask you about left
and right it's not a crucial thing to
and it's widely misunderstood brexit was
not about left versus right we weren't
arguing in the e referendum about the
role of the state in the economy and how
to be best in inequality we were talking
about immigration about sovereignty and
what our relation should be towards a
institutional phenomenon that can be
regarded as an example of the wider
process of globalization all right the
and whether or not if I ask you a series
of questions about your attitude
towards inequality and incentives on the
rest of it and I do that it hard it does
not enable me at all to predict whether
you voted remain or leave left wingers
were as likely to vote leave as we're
right-wingers okay the division in the
EU referendum was between social
liberals and social conservatives and
this isn't arguments about what it kind
of society you are comfortable living in
on what kind of society you think
Britain should be so a social liberal is
somebody who says look I don't care what
your religion is I your sexual practices
are up to you the market what moral code
you follow is ultimately up to you what
language you speak is up to you whether
or not you salute the Union jackal what
symbols you decide to adhere to or
respect is up to you I'm by the way I
love living in London it's a fantastic
diverse City and so these are people who
are comfortable indeed embrace the idea
of social diversity there are sensually
people within today so look it's up to
individuals to decide social and moral
code and the religious code exception
they live in but at the other end of the
spectrum there's an argument we might
call a social conservative that says no
look at the end of the day if a society
is going to have at least an adequate
degree of social cohesion then actually
society does need to some degree at
least need to be able to enforce a
common moral code it's a good idea that
actually if we do all have some sense of
common adherence to a set of national
symbols it is a good idea certainly that
if we all speak the same language and of
course also what tends to be true that
people this disposition therefore tend
to be rather uncomfortable with a
diverse environment these are the people
who would echo Nigel Farage's comment
that you know they are uncomfortable
when they cannot hear English being
spoken on a bus these are people of
course who tend to live outside of
London because if you live in London and
you hear English being spoken on the bus
comes to something of a surprise so so
but there but this is an important
argument about what is the best way of
organizing society now social liberals
voted remain overwhelmingly social
conservatives voted for leave now this
is an animus this has always been an
element of our politics it won't
surprise you to hear because the secret
is in the name Liberal Democrats have
always done relatively well amongst
social liberals like by no means get all
the sociable but those who vote Liberal
Democrat are disproportionately social
liberal and now and Liberal Democrats
are more clearly demarcated by those
social liberalism than being on the left
or the right indeed they will be uncut
party tends to Smither a bit on the
left-right spectrum you know sometimes
things to the left and then swings back
to the right now this wings bite left
again and testicle itself centrist you
kept you keep voters by the way are not
right-wing all those when the UK was
remind blood we're not right we will get
voters don't like inequality right yeah
that they're a bit where they will
sometimes do a depart from others is
they're not quite sure they trust the
state to do anything about it but me I
remember you kippers are people who
don't like the way that Britain is going
in a whole variety of ways and it isn't
just about immigration it's also about
economic inequality so you could pretend
to be on left but that social
conservatives so the finger for but in
what you would normally have expected in
an election twenty something about
brexit we expect the Romanians to go to
the local Democrats and you would expect
the social conservatives and the levers
to go to UK well the the leavers decided
but their best chance was going with the
Conservatives and you kept looking was
beginning to look like a busted flush
and they were Democrats still struggling
to recover from the sins as many people
see it of the coalition okay so the two
parties whom you would expect and indeed
during you know much repair previous
period have been articulating that
social liberal social conservative
divide where every week so what happened
the Conservatives lost ground amongst
remainders and gained ground amongst
leave us their vote
therefore it become it was always a bit
socially conservative but their vote
becomes more clearly socially
conservative on the labor side yes lemon
party does gain a ground much Devers but
against more ground amongst remainders
one of things by the way that I spent
might now just upset many of your
audience in my view in many ways Jeremy
Corbyn in 2017 achieved what Tony Blair
had been trying to deliver for years
which was to deliver a middle class
social liberal University graduate fact
Corbin's electorate is much more
obviously Blair right than either the
Blair lights or the Corbin Easter's
would like to believe because Corbin's
was not particularly successful or no
more successful namely about Bernie
getting left-wing voters in his success
was getting in social liberals now but
then the crucial turnout for what we're
then getting we're getting conservative
and labour not only now having to
articulate the left-right divide with
which they are comfortable but they're
now having finding themselves
articulating this social liberal social
conservative device around Sony percent
of the conservative vote is socially
conservative right - remainer around 70%
of laman vote is social liberal and it
is because over sliver the Labour vote
is is remainer and given that there is
virtually no statistical lengthe so the
probability that you are on the left in
the way that I have defined it is more
or less unrelated to whether you are a
social liberal social conservative right
so we've now got these two dimensions
everything about you've got two
dimensions all right and you're going to
articulate those two dimensions and
they're orthogonal to each other right
angles to each other you really need
four parties yes yeah but it's been
articulated by two so conservative
labour are both being deeply disrupted
because they are now finding themselves
tackling an issue which is not a
left-right issue it's an issue that took
two different set of values a certain
values that they are not at heart of
what they are about but which is deeply
disruptive of their normal electoral
coalition's and therefore they are
struggling to deal with
they assure as well as the fact they're
also deeply polarized about brexit
[Music]